fifteen thousand dollar Mac Pro versus
an M2 Pro Mac Mini surely this tiny
thing cannot be more powerful than this
system right well the M1 Mac Mini was
already very powerful but the Mac Pro
did beat it out in a lot of key real
world hard-hitting productivity tasks
but now that we have the Mt Pro
Everything Has Changed we're gonna be
going over a ton of different real world
workflows and showing you guys the
differences and the few things where the
Mac Pro still does better and why some
of you guys might want to buy one of
these now this thing was 15 grand brand
new here are the full specs to show you
guys and the specs of the M2 Pro Mac
Mini now I did spec this up with one
gigabit Ethernet with extra Ram with
extra storage average so it's definitely
not the 599 dollar Mac Mini but the
afterburner card that was in this that I
sold that was two thousand dollars by
itself and the graphics card was two
thousand eight hundred dollars so
there's still such a crazy price
difference starting out with geekbench 5
the 12 core Mac Mini beats out the 12
core Xeon by about 20
until this point no apple silicon
MacBook or Mac beat out the Mac Pro's
sheer CPU horsepower but with this new
12 core it finally does now because of
this you might expect cpu-based tasks to
be 20 faster but that is not going to be
the case now in terms of single core
performance we went from 1100 up to a
thousand nine hundred and thirty six
that is 74 fast here and let me tell you
you could tell the dear friends even
opening up files and folders this Mac
Pro just feels slow and because of that
when you're web browsing everything
loads way faster in speedometer 2.0 the
Mac Mini is 2.2 times faster it is so
Snappy for web-based applications it
definitely makes a difference and with
that it also has Wi-Fi 6E but not only
that even the regular Wi-Fi six five
gigahertz is way faster the older Macs
wouldn't let me use the full speed that
my internet gave me but with this one I
get 57 faster download speeds and
denoising audio files which we do all
the time are not 20 faster it's more
than twice as fast now we also compress
and decompress files and I wanted to do
a longer test so I used xcode which is
tough and instead of taking 20 minutes
the Mac Mini did it in 12. so so that is
close to twice as fast and then for
unzipping instead of taking five and a
half minutes it did so more than twice
as fast instead of a 20 difference like
we saw in geekbench so now you know you
can't just trust Benchmark so that is
the CPU but what about graphics
performance that's why we have this
Beast of a card here well with
geekbenches metal this thing got almost
a hundred thousand compared to 51 400.
the Mac Pro has twice the performance so
it should destroy it right well let's
get to the real world test so we do have
a benchmark called gfx bench which is
metal gaming performance and here I was
shocked to see that with our Fair
off-screen test the Mac Mini actually
scored five frames per second higher so
it's beating it instead of having half
the performance because of the
optimizations and the unified memory
system now while it was doing so instead
of pulling 250 Watts for the graphics
card it only used 30. so it's using less
than 1 8 of the power to beat it out in
performance that is crazy now as for
professional design using figma this
project was provided to us by 500
designs one of the best in Los Angeles
and the macro
disappointed it was glitchy and stuttery
it was running terrible compared to the
Mac Mini which runs just as well as the
brand new MacBooks that we have tested
the new M2 Pro chips load things up
instantly when you zoom in and then we
exported these 12 high resolution layers
and the M2 Pro Mac Mini took a minute
and 35 seconds compared to 2 minutes and
25 seconds for the Mac Pro so the Mac
Mini is about 57 faster now what happens
when we push the CPUs to their limits
and what about fan noise in and heat
well we use cinebench and here for the
first time ever the Mac Mini be out the
Mac Pro where in the past even the M1
Max couldn't stand up to this 12 core
Zeon so I am very impressed but what is
more impressive is that it did that only
using 33 and a half watts compared to an
average of
185 Watts for that Xeon it actually
Peaks at 193 so the Mac Pro needs five
and a half times more power to achieve
less performance so what about the
temperatures this thing has three large
fans in the front these massive heat
sinks both in the graphics and the CPU
and it stays silent all the time it's
designed to handle up to 28 cores
multiple graphics cards and this thing
is Tiny the cooler in there is super
small well the Mac Mini stayed silent
when it was maxing out the CPU in that
stress test now it did run at about a
hundred degrees celsius compared to
about 70 for the Mac Pros it's a lot
hotter but that is because of Apple's
tuning the only run the fans at about
2300 RPMs where they could go all the
way up to 5 000
um with the system so they want to keep
it quiet now you can go in and use TG
fan Pro we'll Link in the description
you can kick that up a bit to have it
run cooler but that's what Apple
designed it to do now I also wanted to
see what happens if we max out the CPU
and the GPU is this thing going to
overheat with a tiny fan we know the Mac
Pro doesn't and surprisingly no it
didn't the CPU ran at 98 degrees Celsius
and the graphics at 82 which is coolier
than I thought and the fan wasn't even
maxed out so this thing can handle
maxing everything out which is really
awesome and now let's get into some real
world productivity tasks other than 3D
rendering and what we tested running our
xcode compiling tests the Mac Pro took
125 seconds which is good but the Mac
Mini shocked me at 70 seconds that is 75
percent faster absolutely insane so if
you're a coder this thing flies now if
you work with logic we have our logic
Benchmark that tests how much load the
system can handle there are some
plug-ins you guys can look that up and
although the Mac Mini did not beat out
the Mac Pro it got very close where in
the past the Mac Pro was the PowerHouse
for music production now this is a good
time to talk about all the PCI slots
because you obviously do not get it with
the Mac Mini but what a lot of people
don't know is that you could still use
an external enclosure with the Mac Mini
over Thunderbolt and we do have four
Thunderbolt ports here and you can put
in Blackmagic deck Link cards you can
put in external ssds and they even make
these modules where it can literally
hold your Mac Mini in there and then
give you a bunch of connections on the
front you can put in a bunch of PCI
cards and then tether Thunderbolt out of
that as well so it is super cool now you
can't add external Graphics but
everything else from sound cards and
capture cards you can do you can even
put it into a rack mount like you can
with the rack mountable Mac Pro now if
that's Overkill they have these sets
that can hold three cards externally
just a little box or if you're on a
budget they have these ones for 265
bucks they'll hold any PCI slot and then
you can actually take the Thunderbolt
and connect something else as well and
these are fun Thunderbolt 4 instead of
Thunderbolt 3 so each one of these can
be split out into three Thunderbolts
with owc's inexpensive dock so for most
people there's not really a reason to
buy a Mac Pro anymore and that's maybe
why nobody wants to buy mine even at
four thousand dollars and now let's get
into photo editing 3D rendering and
video editing starting out with photo
editing I use the new Affinity 2 which
has a built-in Benchmark in here in
terms of CP performance the Mac Mini
scored 60 percent higher which I also
didn't expect because in geekbench we
saw a 20 difference now in terms of
raster Metal Graphics the Mac Pro did
still
etch out the Mac Mini by a bit but then
with the combined score the Mac Mini
still did way better almost three times
as much and that is just if you have
tasks that can only do the CPU on the
GPU and you're combining layers that way
it's a lot harder and the Mac Mini
excels now in Lightroom this is one area
that the Mac Pros uh six Channel memory
having a ton of ram made it destroy
other systems it was insane I was
shocked to see that the mac and mini had
the same exact export time for 50 raw
edited high resolution images as the Mac
Pro that has never happened before ever
and this tiny thing can do it now I also
tested creating a panorama and the mini
beat out the Mac Pro by 21
and then I used Photoshop to create a
high quality HDR image from 10 50
megapixel files and the mini was 47
faster so that is another area where the
Mac Pro excelled and it was worth buying
it before but not anymore now what about
blender 3D rendering they've made
updates so you can actually use Metal
Graphics to render and everything got a
lot faster in the sheer horsepower you
guys saw in geekbench metal twice the
score allowed it to do very well I
thought the mini was going to get smoked
in this department because it's not a M1
Max or an Mt Max it has 19 cores but I
was surprised to see that it was only
slightly behind in the simple BMW test
now I threw something harder at it which
is the party tug which has a bunch of
very very complex lighting and here the
mini was once again slower but not by a
huge amount at all and one thing I
noticed is the amount of memory
bandwidth at Peak was more than two and
a half times higher on the Mini compared
to the Mac Pro and this thing has hbm2
memory that's very fast and that is once
again because of unified architecture
there's no duplication that has to
happen it's way more efficient and so I
threw our memory test added and this is
a blender project that requires a lot of
memory and here the many actually beat
out the Mac Pro by almost twice the
amount of time so if you have blender
projects and need a lot of memory
these Apple silicon computers are so
good at that and now let's talk about
video editing which is the reason why I
got this computer it was so much faster
than anything else at the time
stabilizing a one minute 4K clip took 14
seconds on the Mac Pro that's fast but
the mini did so in four seconds yes four
seconds that is absolutely insane so
when you're rendering effects this thing
flies way faster than what the
benchmarks will show now when you're
editing simple 4K footage both these
systems don't have any issues with it
they play back perfectly even with
effects but exporting a five minute 4K
project we see in Final Cut it is very
similar the mini is just slightly faster
but then I decided to give DaVinci
Resolve a try because they've been
really working on optimizing for these
Apple silicon systems in the same exact
test took a minute and 26 seconds but
for the Mac Pro it actually took longer
than it did with Final Cut so this shows
that Apple isn't really caring about
Final Cut they're not optimizing it at
least for the full performance of these
new systems Apple please step it up
flipping from that I want to throw the
toughest video editing task and that is
denoising raw footage and DaVinci
Resolve I have a lot of denoising here
and the Mac Pro can do this at 18 frames
per second where the mini only does
seven that shows you the raw grunt of
the graphics cards and these systems
clearly this thing is still a beast and
you can add in more but when it comes
time to playing back 10-bit footage like
HDR from the R5 the Mac Pro couldn't do
so it stutters it cannot handle whereas
the mini could do so perfectly and if
you're exporting this type of footage
the mini is more than three times faster
so if you're working with this kind of
footage you have to transcode it first
to do so on the Mac Pro but not on the
mini and when you're transcoding 30
minutes with the footage it takes 30
minutes on the Mac Pro the mini does
that in 8 minutes and it doesn't even
need to do that now there's only two
more tests I wanted to do the first one
is with prores which a lot of people use
now for the system I had the afterburner
which cost two thousand dollars and it
was well worth the money at the time but
the mini has that built in but way
better exporting graded prores raw to
prores took 2 minutes and 45 seconds on
the Mac Pro and then it went down to a
minute 45 if you spent that two thousand
dollars but the midi can do so in 48
seconds
for basically the price of just that
afterburner that is insane and making it
even harder I want to test out red 8K
footage this does not make use of any
prores encoders or decoders or it's not
limited by faster encoders for h0265
it's just super tough it needs a lot of
high performance to do so and here the
Mac Pro was faster but by barely
anything and this is another category
where this thing used to beat out every
other system but not anymore and I will
just say once again I didn't think that
this mini could be this close or beat
out the Mac Pro and certain things by
this much
for something that costs way less money
and it is this small and then the whole
thing with uh having external cards that
is no longer an issue too now the Mac
Pro does have more Thunderbolt ports but
you can split them off here like I
mentioned nobody needs to buy one of
these anymore and nobody is buying mine
and I know exactly why you guys let me
know your thoughts down in the comment
section below check out one of those
great videos right over there click that
Circle above to subscribe to see more
videos and I'll see you in the next one
foreign